[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are unboxing volume right
now we are figuring out how to balance
our gut health we know so little about
this bacteria and everything that lives
inside of us right here there's more
bacterial cells than human cells inside
of our body
these cells are billions of years old
human cells are only millions of years
old so this is very exciting there's
more genetic expressions that happen
here than in our human cells as well
with genes so let's try and figure out
our gut health so in order to do so we
have volume here volume is helping us
take a look inside of our gut and get
this personalized action plan for what
to do so our friends over volume have
sent us a kit to unbox and check out and
understand better exactly what to do and
I really appreciate what they're doing
because again this is a really important
step for us to figure out about our
biology and about maximizing our health
so shout out to viola and Naveen Jain
thank you very much for sending over the
kit and we have a fro those that are
interested in participating in this
process with us and understanding your
own microbiome we have a discount code
it's simulation at the links in the bio
just type in simulation get a hundred
bucks off your vinyl border so it'll be
two hundred ninety nine dollars so go
check that out
alright so now as we kind of look into
this like I want to bring up a couple
things as you know even prior to
unboxing this just so you guys get an
idea of exactly what we're doing here so
something that really stuck as I was you
know looking at volume VI ome calm here
and you know as you look through kind of
what they're saying here this is some
cutting edge technology that was
developed for the national security at
Los Alamos National Lab so this is some
some top edge stuff and they're aiming
to detect nutrients and toxins being
produced by the microbiome and give
personalized recommendations food and
nutrients to heal your gut hopefully to
not have chronic conditions so you know
their app here looks like they're you
know showing you about your wellness
breakdown in your inflammatory activity
digestive activity foods that you should
enjoy foods that you should minimize
which is very interesting because you
know Naveen was teaching me that it's
not just there's there's no universal
truth to everybody that's applicable
about what they should eat which is
crazy because you think like spinach is
probably good for everybody but this is
crazy interesting stuff so as I want to
unpack a little bit more about the
science you know they send you this kit
and then they collect samples and then
they analyze it and give you this
feedback back on the app and so now this
is really interesting they identify
strains of all organisms this means
bacteria viruses fungi phages yeast
parasites etc in your gut and how these
organisms produce nutrients are toxins
from the food that we eat and they use
AI engine you can lose those you can
zoom in a little bit on that okay yes
will be when we get a little zooming
good call Ron thank you and so as you
see here this is a long list of stuff
not just bacteria but viruses fungi
phage Aziz parasites that's so much to
analyze this is called meta
transcriptomics which is very
interesting it will we'll unpack this
right here as we go to the science page
I thought this was really interesting
the difference between volume and other
gut biome companies so most people are
just doing a meta genomic analysis but
volume does a meta transcriptomics
analysis and so what we see here is we
see that you identify all these
microorganisms living in your gut and
you get a high resolution of all of them
quantify the biochemical activities
identify which metabolites are being
produced in which are missing
and the correlation of microphones are
the functions with chronic common
chronic conditions so actionable
recommendations can be made so this is
very exciting stuff and I think another
really important point here is that
right here this is because microbes in
your gut produced thousands of chemicals
called metabolites these affect your
overall wellness and so this is really
important that some of these can cause
coronary artery artery disease and some
of them such as are beneficial to our
health like vitamin B and short chain
fatty-acids
so without further ado let's go ahead
and unbox biome and explore this in more
detail so here what's really cool about
volumes kit is you know I really like
this conflicting food advice is now
obsolete on one side on the other side
imagine living in a world where illness
is optional very visionary stuff and you
know Naveen is also the CEO of founder
of moon express as well which is aiming
to go to the moon so you know this is
very like visionary stuff a world
without illness and conflicting food
device advice being obsolete so let's go
ahead and this is what happens when I
don't prepare and bring a scissors I'm
just gonna open it that way
all right so
all right so as we unpack we see that
the kind of the box is located inside of
another inside of a sleeve okay so that
was the sleeve and here's the actual
kind of kind of box and it looks it
looks pretty it looks quite nice you
know it has like a you know a folding
flap like quite a nice Oh fancy it's
quite fancy yeah here we have you know
let's get started so it says create your
account you know which we've already
done we've already made our account
complete your questionnaires which is
very important to do you've got to
complete your questionnaire as well and
then that questionnaire is what is
analyzed at the same time as the
returning sample and that was who gives
you the they analyze your test results
and then get your results and
recommendations okay let's get started
nice gut intelligence oh it's another
it's another kind of little box inside
of thank you for ordering nice is quite
nice packaging interesting all right
so gut intelligence let's see what's in
here so as we open this up we have
this pack that comes out it looks like
we have it's like looks like a little
bit of liquid it's and I'm not sure if
this is for which which at which sample
this is for will read will read and
we'll figure it out aha
we got some instructions on the side
okay three easy steps follow the
instructions to complete your gut
intelligence test one collect use the
tape measure to take your waist and hip
measurements you will enter this
information to the app in the
questionnaire section are we going to do
that live and we gonna do this live what
we gonna do we gonna defecate on the
show so we tell you that we should do
that we'll say I'm you know let's do
this to good taste biomedicine it's
important stuff that's not obscene or
lascivious hold on a moment
yeah yeah on sec that's so great we will
definitely do another you know navin's
coming on the show later in august as
well as we're doing some short clips
with them about this content so see ya
well we'll keep you posted on this okay
so you were using this too interesting
so we're using a tape measure first for
tape measure yeah I know interesting to
see how long yeah you'll is nota to take
your waist and hip measurements and so
you're gonna use this I know but it
windows come out that's like wow wow is
that live inside and let's be Seri let's
be serious
so yes okay so waist and hip
measurements
okay so we're giving them important data
and it's a it's exciting to know exactly
how they're gonna end up using that that
data as well and to stool collection
papers of different sizes use the one
that fits your toilet the best okay
interesting so stool collection
ah I was wondering how they were going
to have us have us collected so so this
is this is placed on the toilet oh and
it's taped to the toilet okay you rip
you rip these out and you have your
empties up and you tape them to the
toilet like like this if this was the
toilet bowl and so it sits like that and
then when you take a poop you defecate
you're gonna take the pulpit we have to
talk to any returns okay and it sits
there and then from there then you okay
ensure that the paper snake slightly
carefully deposit your stool onto the
paper okay so that's how you collect
carefully deposit your stool on the
paper did they you have a little fork or
anything in there like tiny little Forks
the paper go ahead and then transfer so
untap the brown tube be careful not to
spill the solution inside okay that's
this that's this guy right here and use
the attached scoop to transfer one small
scoop not heaping what's a heaping scoop
they're trying to tell you just take a
small bit of your feces don't fill the
whole tube with your fecal matter and
close tightly overloading the tube will
cause problems with the analysis okay so
this is really important so take that
one small scoop so here you can see I'll
bring this up close there is a little
scoop here and so you know you want to
keep it about that size of the scoop
right there
so okay and this says shake vigorously
for 30 seconds allow the tube to rest
for 30 seconds repeat the shake rest
steps two more times so interesting so
they want they have these balls in here
too and I think these balls end up
breaking up to the feces with the
solution and then it breaks it up to a
point of it being more easy for them to
analyze and then you shake rest for 30
shake for 30 rest interest
okay ship place the brown tube in the
rigid safety bag and sealed the bag
placing the prepaid return envelope and
ship within 24 hours
interesting prepaid yeah prepaid here's
first-class package return service
prepaid I'll put it up I'll put it on
this cam as well exempt human specimen
time-sensitive USPS and then here's the
biohazard bag of course yeah
biohazard please don't open this up and
investigate it because it's got fecal
matter in it and interesting so awesome
so this is an interesting unpackaging
experience and how this works so what
what we're gonna do is we're gonna I I
don't know if this is for you know this
is interesting how they want you to
collect it because then you don't like
put your hand in the toilet and all that
other kind of stuff but I personally
don't mind that much I've touched my own
feces before so it's not that big of a
deal for me but thank you for sharing
that what it was so this is this is very
this is very interesting to unpack and
understand this better and I'm really
excited to be able to do more show of
really interesting future technology
like this so now yeah let's talk about
like you can ship it off we remind us
for what what are they gonna do to it
guys analyze it and yes yes let's talk
about that again so there's this there's
this insane amount of analysis that
needs to be done in our gut for us to
understand us and that means we have
evolved over billions of years thank
goodness to have lived on this rock now
today but specifically just the last
hundred million or sorry just the last
six million or so years we have evolved
from monkeys into humans and that means
our humans
are these are just brand-new basically
these human cells have evolved in our
brand new pretty much versus bacterial
cells the bacterial cells that are
located inside of our gut actually are
we've had quite a bit of conversation
about how they are not so much we are in
control but the gut is in control when
was the last time that you before you
even knew it that you realize you were
at the fridge or opening up a cabinet
looking for food what did you come up
with the conscious decision to go over
there and get food sometimes yes but
sometimes no it makes you wonder who's
actually in control and also what
exactly you're eating and how that's
affecting you so these are billions of
years old these microbes they were
around first on the earth before humans
evolved well I don't get it how is that
how is that possible the good that is by
there's that what there's something
inside you that's older yeah oh then the
millions of years that you are but
billions of years and that's through
your fecal matter through your
microbiome so the evolution of of
neurology so act and and for first of
all bacteria even before neurons even
before neurology bacteria and bacterial
genetic expressions so the first
single-celled organisms then the first
multicellular organisms then the
development of neural systems like the
neural infrastructure even prior to us
of the initial primordial beings such as
the fish in the oceans during the
Cambrian explosion and then the
reptilians that took on onto the land
and then even passed that to now where
we are today and yeah it's crazy to
think about that that there's so much
genetic expression that happens here
millions of genetic expressions happen
here versus just tens of thousands
happen from our human cells does it have
anything to do with your gut instinct
your gut feeling is that you've got like
when your eyes is telling you something
you've got is that what it really boils
down to you know the the billions of
years
now yeah could be that yeah exactly
maybe that has to do with that like [ __ ]
yeah or no when your first feeling out
situations or when like you said you
have this intuition
who knows maybe it is coming from that
wisdom or that knowledge of the billions
of years in the microbiome so so yeah so
so as you think about this there is all
of this bacteria viruses fungi phages
yeast parasites etc it just blows my
mind to think that that's all located
right here and we got to know whether
they're producing nutrients toxins from
the food that we eat and then to
leverage things like artificial
intelligence to be able to parse this
sample and then be able to give us these
recommendations about the exact foods
that we should be eating in order to
minimize the chronic conditions that
occur like inflammation inflammatory
bowel syndrome Crohn's disease these
things are rampant all of the the issues
that we have with our skin like in Zuma
and and also keeping the goal of our gut
balanced in general so I want to come
back to these screen shots again cuz I
think these are really important who
knew that you would once be you know
getting told that you know these are the
foods to enjoy based on your microbiome
these they're foods to minimize based on
your microbiome and all the analysis so
yeah I'm really excited to try this out
it's really awesome too and we'll keep
you guys posted on how this goes really
grateful to be able to unpack future
technology like this and it looks like
this is gonna be a lot of fun
thank you everybody for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it if you guys you
know if you guys had a good time with
with what we've been unpacking here
about you know gut intelligence and
about conflicting food advice being
obsolete also about eradicating
suffering and living healthy for longer
knowing more information about ourselves
this body is such a data heavy
gene that has so much information that
we don't know how to parse and make
applicable to our lives so this is a
really good way to do that and we highly
recommend you checking it out again this
there's a code simulation links in the
bio it's a hundred dollars off so the
kits down to $2.99 and you know we don't
make any money just openly and
transparently we make no money on it
we're doing this on behalf of sharing
this wisdom and sharing this with more
people around the world and we hope that
more people will try this and get to
know it better so yeah thanks everyone
for tuning and go share this with two
other people we're not sure we're not
gonna wanna we're not gonna do the
sample yeah we're not get a nice
close-up steaming pile of feces that's
disgusting
mine would you know the other other
other neuroscience and bio scientists
that we've been talking to I what when
are they gonna work on our digestive
system to kind of clean up that process
not make it so stinky and and and and
disgusting and filthy the whole we per
day the ingest of system were just on
our show yesterday we were talking about
how there are civilizations on other
rocks orbiting stars that might not even
need to have sex to procreate they can
just procreate in other ways you see
that movie cocoon when they had sex in
the pool did you see that film from like
the 80s with them yeah an alien day it
was an alien so now now let me finish by
just saying that sorry
we'll just think just think about this
now Ronnie and he takes them
you take the born you take this which is
we've talked about this several times on
the show we put food in our mouths the
food goes through our digestive tract we
take nutrients from that food and then
we poop out the the leftovers and that
whole notion of flatulence and
excuse me excuse us and then and then
the process of having to take poops now
are there other species orbiting stars
around the universe that don't have to
go through this process hopefully
hopefully that's true and so thanks for
tuning in you know if you guys had a
good time share with two other people
let's get a little bit more people
talking about this and sharing their
wisdoms with other people about the gut
microbiome and just talking about this
more and understanding this data about
us also join us
subscribe comment below to your thoughts
about gut microbiome analysis meta
transcriptomics I'm taking fecal sample
shipping them off getting analysis
keeping more in touch with our bodies in
that sense and join us on patreon help
us support this and continue doing cool
projects like this much love everybody
thank you so much for tuning in shout
out to vol comm definitely go check them
out thanks everybody
[Music]
[Music]